thanks very much it's been called an
unprecedented move the Prime Minister's
release of his tax returns in response
to speculation about his family finances
but is it enough to silence the
opposition while the Shadow Chancellor
John McDonald is here and a very good
morning to you mr. McDonald well first
of all this sir from Angus Robertson
saying well it's moving on now to to the
cabinet and in particular the Chancellor
would you like to have a look at his tax
affairs well I published my own i
published my own some some months ago
and i think actually it's quite good
standard to set in other european
countries this happen happens and i
think people now want the sort of
openness and transparency so it's up to
individual individuals at the moment but
i think i think the system should be
changed a little certainly those who are
taking went the cabinet or shadow
cabinet decisions I think it's quite
important that people but in particular
the Chancellor when he's dealing your
shadow yeah you're shadowing him when
he's dealing with issues like British
overseas territories setting they're
always changing the law he's made to be
chasing down the tax avoiders when I
when I publish mine I said I thought I
did this on a voluntary basis because I
a journalist simply asked me the
question I said yes I will but when I
did my I said actually if you are
dealing with particularly financial
matters and if you're dealing with the
taxation system it's best to be open and
transparent and as I say it happens in
other countries so I don't see a problem
with it I think people should just get
on to it but I mean I want your lead of
a saying this morning that it should be
compulsory for people in public life
particularly em please thank all that
beats you just published so that sister
to that system works elsewhere perfectly
well and I think now that people are the
general public are really concerned
about the fairness of taxation system so
i think yes it would set a good standard
for us all well i got your tax return
here just want to ask you couple
equations about i mean there's not much
in their part for your mp's salary you
don't give any money to charity well i
do but i don't get very many occasions
but it would be tax efficient for them
as i'm sure the charity or charities
would tell you but it's this term you've
got a pension Avenue from Westminster
Council 14,000 pounds plus some did you
take a tax-free lump sum when you access
that no I don't think there was a
tax-free lump sum with that there wasn't
an option because that equates something
like a 300,000 no no there wasn't there
wasn't a tax-free them so i don't
believe that was available it's a local
government scheme
and I'm 64 now so I qualify for it I
paid into it in the normal way so I
declared it and what you'll see for my
tax return what I have is my MP salary
and my local government yeah but I'm
just asking about the tat you know the I
mean the very legitimate ways and ways
that the government encourages and the
labor administration in the past have to
to avoid tax ID I think I'm safe have
you got Isis as well I mean I've attacks
I've got one small I so having 5,000
pounds or something like that now but
again I think that's what we're saying
is if it's open and transparent and a
nicer for example is to encourage people
to save it's perfectly proper so I don't
see any problem about being completely
open and transparent about all those
matters if you're a politician at a
senior level making decisions on
taxation what people are concerned about
is why I say so it's wider than that
they'll be just just on what me i'm
corbin said this money just said
everyone in public life is even well yes
I thought journalists asked you lot
question of this thing do you agree with
that well I think there's a note I think
I would like it to me is open and
transparent as possible generally
started the debate on that Mound I think
that's going to be really useful but as
a first step I think actually what
senior politicians I think voluntarily
now they should do it anyway and what
about your colleague means sink akali
because the the shadow foreign secretary
Hillary been we know that sir when when
his father passed and a lot of mr.
Cameron's affairs were about inheritance
sir when Tony been passed away there was
there was a very very expensive house in
Holland Park that he passed on to his
family in it and it seems that there
were legal devices used by the family to
mitigate tax do you think you would
encourage mr. been to publish his tax
affairs I think anyone now my own view
is this anyone at a senior level in
politics who are making decisions or
potentially making decisions shadow
cabinet for example about the taxation
of affairs of our country it's better to
be completely open and transparent it's
voluntary at the moment but I'd like to
see a system as I say operates in other
countries I don't see why it doesn't
here but people asking these specific
questions about Hilary Benn you'd say
Hillary get on with it and show us what
habits up to the individual concern but
I think it's best to be open transparent
and now I want to ask about this same
amount hotter your colleague in in the
shadow Treasury team
writing today she's saying and this is
on Mr Cameron even now we don't know if
he's telling the full story what are
they labor parties concerned we haven't
seen the full tax returns yet always
done his publisher a summary from his
accountant so it's not the publication
you said oh she's publishers tax returns
he hasn't done it all together really I
think the question I don't want to
personalize this around David Cameron
but what worried people is he was asked
a straight question a week ago and you
expect from your Prime Minister
automatically a straight answer we
didn't get that and it's taken us a week
to get this far to get this amount of
information we still haven't had the
full tax returns so I think people are
still querulous about what is the exact
position itself people are asking
questions today about the inheritance
that he's had as well three hundred
thousand pounds from his father just
below the inheritance tax levels of the
325 then to lump sums a hundred thousand
from his mother which takes his
inheritance then to 500,000 person he
never paid any tax on it whatsoever so
again there's an issue here that people
say look there's one the law for the
rich there's another for the rest it
just has to be rich I mean it's entirely
within the law you suggesting the
developing under waters gone not at all
but what people are saying is the system
fair and shouldn't we review the system
to see if it is fair as I say never paid
a penny of inheritance tax on that and
the government now is cutting
inheritance tax the reason people are
asking questions whether it's fair
enough I just give one example at the
same time in the budget they're cutting
inheritance tax at the same time they
were cutting benefits for disabled
people are 30 pounds a week people just
don't think that's fair and that's not
the way that I think they'd like to see
our system operate and just on the prime
minister then would you like to go
further back as well and find out about
offshore trusts and offshore investment
vehicles whether he's hot weather he's
had investments in my past I think the
fund a long time ago I think it's better
for him to be completely open and
transparent over that period the other
thing that I think people are asking
questions about which is again policy
not personality at the same time as we
were campaigning I've been campaigning
on this last 15-20 years same time as we
were campaigning we had a real victory
about registering beneficial interests
in companies he was blocking in Europe
the registration of interest in trusts
and again that's not open and
transparent
that he was proclaiming he was a about
that isn't what he was actually doing it
when I to a lot more isolation I want to
ask you a lot more about overseas
dependencies and Grand territories but
just on this this trust blairmore it was
called and of course that resonates with
people in terms of a former leader of
your party who now we understand is very
very rich indeed ranges these tax of as
i'm sure entirely legally but of course
lids in many different jurisdictions
around the world you think tony blair's
image and tony blair's wealth is
damaging to your party it's not about
the wealth as such of our individuals
you know you can have wealthy people is
whether the system is fair in terms of
taxation if they're paying their taxes
fairly that's fine and legally that's
fine but I think we're into a really
moral discussion now about whether our
taxation system really is fair and is it
actually creating a society that solving
sorta like shadow chancellor the
specific question about Tony Blair
former from a leader of your party of
course you're an entirely new leadership
now but you know in the public's mind
they're saying well there was a labor
leader who after he left office has made
an awful lot of money and arranged his
taxes according knowing i don't know
about his tax affairs he certainly made
a large amount of money what he does
with that money i'm not sure he might
well be using for good purposes i don't
know this isn't about people being rich
or people just all people just been on
average wages this is is this system
treating everybody fairly the system
isn't treating people fair that's the
general view at the world particularly
if you can use various tax devices to
avoid paying tax on quite a large scale
that isn't open to the ordinary person
who goes to workplaces PA ye so that's
why the system needs to be reformed okay
well and the irony of this is of this
system many of the territories that
allow this to happen now of course the
relationship with in with the UK what
would you do to the british services i
think their ability to offer these kind
of well I think we've got to enforce a
standard upon them of openness and
transparency and tax regimes within
their territories that are fair as well
and that reflect what we want in this
country as well and if they don't abide
by that my own view is that we should
take action against them and if they
themselves are largely supported by the
UK if they want to go independent that's
up to them but
to be frank the OECD would must probably
list them and blackness the Miss tax
havens anyway so it is better for them
to cooperate with the UK government have
openness and transparency register the
interests of people that hold their
wealth within those those territories
and pay appropriate level goes for crown
dependencies goes for the Isle of Man
goes yes I think we've got to try and
get agreements now internationally and
globally about fair taxation we've been
campaigned for that in Europe so that
the least we can do is make sure those
that are have a relationship with
Britain should operate effectively well
this this from former deputy leader
Deputy Prime Minister John Prescott this
morning Lord Prescott he says to me they
british virgin islands in the Isle of
Man and other British overseas
territories that promote their
aggressive offshore status and nothing
but parasites well I have to say this
that some of these some of these
territories have actually used our
services been supported by this
government by successive governments by
the UK even received aid some of them
and at the same time they're allowing
their territories to be used as tax
havens I don't think the British
probably think that's fair and I think
it has to be tackled that's one of the
issues we're saying to the government
that they need to get on with quickly
now we're calling for an inquiry now
into Panama and into all these aspects
of it but we want that pop queen choir
to be public and independent the
government setting up an inquiry but
it's reporting to the Home Secretary and
the Chancellor now they're politicians
from physical party whose donors have
actually benefited from the system so
it's hardly independent we also need to
have the hmrc properly resourced stop
the cuts make sure the tax collectors
are properly resourced to be able to
undertake this inquiry but parasites
well I'm afraid if they're taking money
from us if they're enjoying our
protection and their use in the name of
Britain as well and the same time they
are operating as tax havens denying tax
resources to our public services I can
understand why John has gone that far
going to be talking to the First
Minister of vertebral to one of these
parasites is so mr. Prescott and Lord
Prescott you've turned them now I mean
there is an answer a specific answer
with the Gibraltar given the dispute
with Spain is some hand them over well
that's not whether the people they want
if they want a relation
ship with Britain though they should
play fair everybody once the
relationship with Britain should play
fair that means openness transparency
proper register of interests and proper
taxation levels they cannot be used to
salt tax away from this country and
every penny that goes in tax avoidance
and sex invasion means a lack of
investment in our NHS lack of investment
in education our public services and
also in benefits to those that really
need them within our country it's not
fair it's not accept and what are your
views I mean we've been talking about
you know the high end about overseas
trusts and all those kind of things that
most people in the country i'm going to
a clue what they are and whether they
can access them or not but of course
there's tax avoidance and tax evasion it
takes place on a grand scale but at a
low level every day on the streets
building sites and houses and brittany's
you know what i'm going to talk about
the cash in hand the economy then the
black economy what would you say to
people for instance that's voted to you
who get a small job done around the
house and the trades person says well
it'll cost you twenty percent less if
you pay cash well it's not legal it's
just not legal and people just have to
abide by the law week whatever level it
is I'm afraid you have to abide by the
law so what's that you have to ask for a
receipt and ask if your VAD registered
well I'm afraid so you have to abide by
the law and the issue for us at the
moment is the vast bulk of our
population we're not losing on all the
estimates we're not losing shoot
billions of pounds as a result of the
odd cash in hand payment although we
need people to apply the estimate is is
that billions are going in the blind not
on a non endian campaign comparison with
what's going on a tax evasion tax
avoidance on an industrial scale in this
country it pales into insignificance but
nevertheless what we're saying is people
need to abide by the law and the law has
to be fair last dimension of this and
it's something that you've talked about
it I suppose in a in another way in the
past it seems that are a lot of big
banks british-based banks some of them
have been involved in in the Panama
papers that being named in the Panama
papers in using this legal firm to
facilitate their clients setting up
certain trusts so kind of deflecting it
to they need looking up yes we've we've
included this week we're publishing our
plan for tackling tax evasion tax
avoidance and enforcing it effectively
and that means also banks being open and
transparent about the reg
their interest as well that they and how
they use these tax havens and again it
does need an independent inquiry into
this whole system now I'd also like to
strengthen the powers of whistleblowers
because we wouldn't have known anything
about this unless there was leaks going
on what we need to do is strengthen the
power of whistle blows SI also we've got
a register of interest with mps as well
at the moment there is a register of
interest but actually they're the levels
about how much you actually declare if
you've got money in overseas trusts we
want that reviewed as well so there's
complete openness and transparency of a
individuals companies trusts and banks
as well in that way we may be able to
restore the faith in our taxation system
as to internal great talking to you
shadow chancellor thank you very much
indeed John McDonald there and you are
watching manhunt on Sky News